we're working on the mesh current method
of a method of analyzing circuits and in
the previous video we set up our circuit
we set up our mesh currents flowing
around these loops within the circuit
and we solve for the ez currents that
was the the current on this side this
current source constrains I three to be
a fixed value so we already know I three
and then we created two equations from
the two independent variables the two
currents here to describe how the
circuit works and in this video we're
going to solve these two equations one
thing to remind ourselves when we define
these mesh currents all of them went in
the same direction
it helps to make them all go in the same
direction but all clockwise in this case
and that's so that when you have this
little pattern down here of i1 minus i2
or i2 minus i3 then it becomes a
familiar pattern and it helps to get the
signs right the other thing to point out
is the reason we're using meshes and not
any other loop in the circuit not
overlapping loops like we could have
gone all the way around the outside in a
loop the reason that meshes in
particular the open areas of the circuit
are a good way to do this method is
because it produces exactly the right
number of equations to solve the circuit
you don't have too few equations and you
don't have too many equations so let me
move the screen up and we'll go to work
on these equations so now we begin step
4 which is to solve the equations and
what I want to do first is just to tidy
up a little bit I'm going to take the
constants and I'm going to put them on
the right-hand side and I'm going to
gather together the terms for I 1 and
the terms for I 2 in separate places so
if we go at the first equation and we
look for i1 it's mentioned here twice so
we get - and it's a combination of R 1
and plus R 2
times i1 and for the i2 term let's see
if I two shows up I too just shows up
once here so it's going to be plus r2 i2
and that's going to be equal to let's
move V over to the other side so V
becomes minus V over here so that's our
first equation
so now let's tidy up the second equation
I 1 terms this is the only i1 term here
so it's plus r2 i2 oops
plus R 2 i1 that's the only i1 term now
if we do i 2 terms we're going to have
minus r2 i2 minus r3 I 2 and minus R for
I 2 so let's do that
this way r2 plus r3 plus r4 x i2
now we have an i3 term in here but we
know what I 3 is i3 we know from this so
I'm just I'm going to write that down
right here that equals minus I there's
lots of minus signs here so let's see if
we can get this right - are four times
minus I 3 is positive
r4 i3 or its negative r4 i and when we
take it to the other side it'll be plus
r4 I let me check that again - are four
times I minus I 3 is a positive sign I
gives it a negative sign and when we
take it to the other side it gets a
positive sign good alright so this is
what our equations look like now let's
keep going
I can continue using symbols for the
resistor values but it's going to get
kind of complicated and it doesn't help
with our understanding so I'm going to
switch over to a specific circuit so
what I did was I filled in some resistor
values here and I put five volts on the
voltage source 1k ohm is 4 R 1 2 K ohms
as R 2 3 K ohms is R 3 3 km 0 and
there's 2 milliamps over here so I'm
just going to write these values under
the equation here so I don't mess up 1 K
2 K 2 K that's 5 volts that's 2k ohms 2k
ohms 3 K ohms and our four was also 3 is
3 and I is 2 milliamps
I'm going to move the circuit down out
of the way a little bit now we have room
for our equation let's let's fill it out
again with the real values so it's going
to be minus 1 plus 2 is 3 I 1 plus 2 I 2
equals minus 5 we know all the resistors
are K ohms and so we can actually scale
our equations down by a factor of a
thousand and you just use the simple
numbers without the case so our second
equation is 2 I 1 minus 2 plus 3 plus 3
is 8 I 2 and that equals 3 K ohms times
2 milliamps is plus 6 so this is getting
close to something we can solve so I
think the way I want to solve this is
I'm going to take this equation here and
multiply it by 4 and then add it to this
equation here and let's see what we get
so 4 times minus 3 is minus 12 and we
add it and we're going to get
four times two is eight minus eight and
I 2 drops out that was the purpose of
the four and that equals 4 times minus 5
is minus 20 plus 6 is minus 14
so I 1 equals minus 14 over 10 or I 1
equals one point 4 milliamps and that's
cool we get to put a box around that so
as a reminder we defined I 1 to be the
mesh current flowing around like this
and I won one point 4 milliamps that's
one of our independent variables
now that we know I won let's just choose
one of our original equations here and
figure out what I 2 is we'll plug in 2
times I 1 which is 1 point 4 milliamps
minus 8 I 2 equals 6 and now we have to
figure out I 2 so let's solve this minus
8 I 2 equals 6 minus 2 times 1 point 4
is 2 point 8 I 2 equals 3 point 2
divided by minus 8 or I 2 equals minus 0
point 4 milliamps and we could draw a
box around that too so let's put that
mesh current in and our mesh current was
that was I - and that equals minus 0.4
milliamps and what that means is that
the current is not as flowing in the
negative direction so it's actually
flowing this way through these resistors
it's actually flowing in the
counterclockwise direction is the
positive current and from before we
already knew I 3 I 3 equals -2 milliamps
so let's do one last thing here let's
figure out the the currents in the
elements let's let's just figure out a
couple of them that one and that one
so that is I r2 and this one is I are
four I are two equals I to - oops I 1
minus I 2 equals I 1 is 1 point 4 minus
negative point 4 and so that current
equals 1 point 8 milli amps and we'll do
one last one will do i r4 that's this
art this is our 4 here
and I are for is i2 minus i3 so that
equals i2 is minus 0.4 minus i3 i3 is
minus 2 milliamps so I R 4 equals 2
minus 0.4 or 1 point 6 milliamps and
there you have it we used the mesh
current method to solve our circuit